what's up everyone my name is Eric Davis
we are here live at 2018 San Diego
comic-con I am with the director and the
cast of one of 2009 teens most
anticipated films Godzilla king of the
monsters
welcome to comic-con thank you thanks
for coming
how would you describe the vibe in
Godzilla king of the monsters both in
terms of how it's a continuation of the
2014 movie and Kong Skull Island to a
certain degree but then also separates
itself as its own thing from those two
films I like to think of film honors all
previous Godzilla and kaiju films going
back to beast from 20,000 fathoms all
the way up to Gareth's movie and Skull
Island what I think we're doing a little
bit differently as it were trying to
bring the mythic aspect the idea that
these giant monsters aren't just giant
monsters but thousands of years ago we
considered them gods and so they're sort
of trying to reclaim the earth as their
own which obviously causes a conflict
now what's interesting is in the 2014
Godzilla
they keep Godzilla away for a while kind
of play like a Jaws vibe with it but
then it come they give you Kong right up
front so are we gonna open with just
some monster brawls yes like is happy to
go yeah we uh we don't hold back in this
one there's a weird scene where Godzilla
is just playing chess with himself okay
yeah top is you kind of like the
connective tissue a little bit like I'm
pretty much the titular character
without being in the title are really in
the movie very much you had a moment you
had a moment in the car movie right I
mean I was a voice on on the phone just
because Jordan and Jordan Bo Roberts the
director of Kong Skull Island and I go
way back and when we started together so
he had to just put me in character no I
know that would be great though that
would mean I haven't aged but we do
bring back one character from the comics
code oh yeah yeah which one is that
you'll have to see the movie all right
you can buy your tickets on Fandango
and definitely do that when they come
back so Milly you you are no stranger to
two things with some monster things you
see what I just did there what can you
tell us about who you play in this movie
and how it's different and how she's
different from anyone you've ever played
well well in in the movie I actually
speak any other project not hinting to
what you know strangest things or
anything but yeah I just speak I have
some quite a few lines which is great so
yes that was a challenge to kind of you
know transition into actually like
having words and and ya know it was it
was fun you know I think you know
compared to like stranger things
stranger things we actually manually
made monsters like with costumes and
then you know with this movie everything
was like tennis balls and like you know
tape and so you know it was very
different in the room now in fact we had
one tooth huge tooth oh yeah I remember
that I'm so ya know severe but it was
really fun and and yeah very different
though now Vera now monarch is is what
is the connective tissue between these
three movies and I believe your
character has something to do with
monarch yes she's a paleo biologist that
works for the company okay and and she's
really keen on preserving these monsters
and protecting them and and every day is
bring your child to work day yes yes yes
just you can see brown eyes and blue
eyes very alike it's okay and then how
would you how do you factor into the
film are you a monarch employee are you
a good extra fighter yeah yes to both
kind of I'm really just a pawn in the
whole grand scheme of things but you
know nobody really in in monster movies
the soldiers kind of get the worst job
because I got to be down there next to
like the feet and things while the
monsters are fighting but I am the I'm a
senior officer I'm the
Chief Warrant Officer in the Special
Forces team s ran by monarchy and we are
G team and we are the grunt work and it
gets uh it gets pretty dangerous in my
line of work saliva raining down it's
pretty sticky sticky Thomas what can you
say about who you play my character Sam
Coleman is the communications liaison
from for monarch the organization that
represents the monsters and the
government so I got a deal with those
bigwigs in Washington well speaking of
the monsters we bring in three iconic
Godzilla monsters to this one motor road
and King Ghidorah and so how are they
different from how we've seen them
previously did you kind of soup them up
a little bit or yeah we modernized them
Gareth did such a great job redesigning
Godzilla and the first one in making it
feel like he was an actual product of
nature you know there's a lot of
reptilian features and scales we did the
same thing with these we took the same
basic silhouettes of the original
characters would be recognizable and
just sort of made them we upgraded them
you know gave them the sort of more
modern interpretation so that they felt
like they actually could have crawled
out of the earth and are they sort of
like are you in different cities you
know I know like sometimes the cities in
these movies become characters too so
are you able to say what cities you're
in you're fighting it's honestly we
travel the world we're in Antarctica
we're in China we are in Boston Boston's
going to get it
we're in jungles where it were
underwater I mean we're it's a global
adventure so Godzilla king of the
monsters Godzilla's king of the monsters
if I was going to come and hang out with
your career with your friends and say
what are you king of when you queen of
what would they say
Milly oh what are you like like I'm king
of like trash reality TV that could I
could I could second that
now queen of I don't know what I would
have to say reality TV I love Keeping Up
with the Kardashians so there you go I
don't know I'm king of looking at the
ground and my latest Dungeons & Dragons
you know being inside yeah
I'm queen of crafting I like that I'm a
crafter I make [ __ ]
that's awesome what are you about soon
I'm for sure king of the video games or
king of the Los Angeles Lakers tell them
what you told me about
he left his PlayStation PlayStation on
pause because they assured me I'd be
back in Los Angeles by 6-7 really so
today so you're playing I'm playing
right what are you I'm gonna run down to
copy a 2k I've just got LeBron James I'm
playing with LeBron James everyday until
we see the real do you play for tonight
as well oh yeah before tonight I can't
pause you caught pools foot can't pause
for tonight for tonight is to abusive
yeah Wow he knows us I know I know I go
way back I go to like NH on 95 days oh
and Red Wings love it so as we kind of
wrap up how do you think this film is
going to surprise fans than most people
who are Godzilla fans seeing the
Godzilla movies they're gonna go see
this what do you think they're gonna be
surprised about what do you want them
talking about when they walk out of the
theater action personally like it also
brings youth to the table and I think
that younger shark underrated no but I
think you know like teenagers my age can
kind of watch it and think I like that's
really cool and and that the character
and that she can kind of kick ass as
well
so I think that's really exciting and it
brings youth into the movie which is
cool yeah I think you're gonna fall in
love with you you're gonna fall in love
with the characters you're gonna fall in
love with the monsters the three-headed
monster Ghidorah yeah I want to fall in
love with a three-headed monster I
caught it I came to my house
to say about with you have to one-one
head at a time they have all different
parties they do actually yeah Godzilla
king of the monsters comes out next
summer May 2019 go see it thanks for
coming by and boy comic-con enjoy your
Hall H experience I can't wait for you
guys to have a good things there thank
you it's lit
[Music]
[Applause]